Towards the end of January 1940,
I was put on a boat to come to England.
Been traveling on my own,
since I was four really, all through the war,
all through the air raids and everything.
I had a teddy bear - a Steiff,
which came with me from Germany.
But when I was in my teens,
they quote unquote 'cousins' decided
that I was too old for a teddy bear,
and buried it in their garden.
The only toy I brought with me from Germany.
I had favorite possessions that I couldn't possibly take.
Some years earlier, I had been taken for a walk
by my mother. And we passed a shop
where there were some round things.
I must have been about five years,
possibly six years old.
And it was explained to me that the world is round.
And these were globes.
Giving a map of the world as it actually is.
So I wanted one.
So we went into the shop and asked how much they cost.
And that put an end to it that I wasn't going to get one.
Some months later, one of my uncles,
he came to Leipzig on business, he stayed with us.
And of course the world imposes
certain obligations on visiting uncles.
I got my globe
and it became one of my favorite possessions
and I studied it and I knew the geography of the world.
I knew where all the principal countries were.
But of course I couldn't possibly take it.
I got an atlas eventually, but not a globe.
I was very sorry to lose that globe.
Of course it would be out of date today.
The little suitcase that she brought on her journey is here.
And inside it I've got some of the things
that I know came across in 1939.
Schoolbooks - I've got some of them here.
I brought back any that she'd kind of written copiously in.
Because I find the most moving thing is handwriting.
The hardest thing to part with
- for me me anyway is anything with handwriting.
And I've got every book that my mother had her name written on.
One book that I don't have, because I couldn't find it.
But I know it existed at one stage
and she must have got rid of it
was one book that had the name 'Sarah' in
All Jewish women were forced to
add the name 'Sarah' to their names.
And my mother had written in one of her books:
Ursula Henrietta Barbara Sarah Michel
That's a real piece of history and I don't have it.
Every single object in this cupboard has a history.
This comes from Bratislava.
And she's got a partner.
These are Slovakian.
So are these: that's a škola or školka - 'školka' means 'school'
My cousin Tony. He lives in Geneva.
Or just outside Geneva.
Has found a collection of books in the Prague Museum,
which belonged to Hugo Friedman.
And he's in the process of trying to recover them.
And this says 'pekár' and that's a 'baker'.
The Wiener Library had a huge collection of books
that belonged to Hugo Friedman.
And these some or other have turned up
in the Prague Museum whether they are part
of the same collection -
(voices blending)
But these are my treasures.
You see, I don't have gold.
I don't have silver.
I was born on the eighth of September 1934.
And I was the middle of three as was by 1936.
We've all got very English, British sounding names.
My older brother was Robert.
I'm Thomas, and I prefer Tom, but there we go.
My younger brother, William
and he preferred being called Bill.
Whether it was something or someone out there
that said to my parents
'You should give your children English sounding names, I don't know.'
But they had another son who was born in 1930.
And he died 1932. And he's buried in the Brünn, Jewish cemetery.
And his name was Michael.
So my parents gave each of their children a middle name,
beginning with the letter M.
So, Bob was Robert Milton, I'm Thomas Montague,
and Bill was William Mortimer.
So, something somewhere must have said to my parents:
You're going to be in a different environment later on in your lives.
These are Tom's toys, his childhood things.
When he came here in the thirties as a little boy
and actually I've just noticed that this is a suitcase
And it says 'Granny' on it, which is very sweet -
- there was a letter in this.
The letter from the palace was
because they sent a belt each to the two princesses
as a thank you for letting them come to England.
So these are part of his car and petrol stations,
Six? No. Six by the time - six or seven.
And these are the toys that we played with.
In many ways it seems like a typical - (paper rustling)
A little boy did it because
And this is a - I think like a cowboy belt? A holster.
And there is a gun and there's a tin helmet.
I only keep everything because my parents kept everything.
She looks to have gingerish hair, but I don't know that that's true.
This may be an artistic impression.
But it's my aunt Hilda and I've no idea what age she is.
But she looks early 20s.
Very formally dressed, going to a party.
Going for a good night out I guess.
But I only wish that the document on the back of it hadn't faded.
And these photographs, these are all - and postcards
- all related to the Kubies.
And we've got hundreds and hundreds of their photographs
Pre-war Jewish lives.
So Kubies and Friedman's.
I really liked them, because it's just them on their holidays
and special days out. They love skiing.
They spent a lot of time in health resorts.
So yeah, they're going all over like Hungary
and Italy and Czech Republic and -
- like a baby, and clearly a baby was born
and they took lots of photographs of them.
And then they're just even more mundane things
with people hanging out there washing or like sitting in the car.
And with pets. Yeah, I like that this is very
'every day' this collection.
That's me! Standing on a sort of balustrade
by aunt's villa my... one of my mother’s sisters.
She was a widow and she had this wonderful villa.
You went up the steps, then there was a sort of mosaic floor.
That's me, being taken for a walk by the Danube.
I'm wearing leggings, beautifully knitted leggings-
This actually got the history behind it.
In 1938, when the Germans went into Austria,
my father was anxious.
And so were other people, so we ended up at his mother's
place in Vrbové.
And here we are all going for a walk
in this little country village and we're playing silly beggars. We just chased our hats.
It's photographs and it's when they are - they are creased.
They've been folded in half and a quarter and-
- father sitting on a horse.
That's from World War One
-is it folded up, because they had to put it discreetly
on their person? Or has it been- yeah
It was put in someone's wallet? Perhaps in their pocket.
Or did they hide it?
Letters from father should be somewhere in here
yes that’s to do with father...
As there were three of us and we all lived in different places.
Father would write a letter - one a week
to a different one of the three of us.
And then we will then pass our letters round.
So, in the end, we all had a letter once a week.
It's one of the last letters, because the last letter
was on my birthday. It arrived in time for my birthday.
It's somewhere in there.
He wrote very nice letters.
He was a good dad.
I can see him in my mind's eye sitting in this-
- one little room, with one chair and a bed
and the tiny table and teaching himself English.
He wanted - yes, he wanted to - that was his aim -
Two weeks after that he was taken away and dead.
My letter started 'Dear Mr and Mrs Alfsen'
'Are you the people who looked after a little,
four year old girl in 1940? 1939-1940?
If so, I'm that little girl.
And it was through my boss at the university
that I found them.
He gave me the address. And then he says:
'Right, it's up to you.'
And that's when I went back into my office.
And I wrote this very, very long letter.
And then a week later, I got a letter back saying that
they were the family that looked after me,
and when am I coming?
So the next thing was to book a passage to go to Norway.
When my mother came, she went to one family
for a fortnight, and then the sort of first
and as it happened, final foster family.
She remembered being the one who had to
tell my mother that the war had started.
And this is the telegram that they received
announcing my mother's arrival.
And she kept- I mean, she was about a hundred and-
a hundred and three when she died.
And she kept that telegram from 1939.
As we get further away from living survivors
that can actually tell us how it happened.
We are relying only on objects that remain.
But we still need a tangible link
to the individuals that owned them.
A little antiseptic powder.
A writing case in which she did actually keep all her mother's-
- a very nice perfume bottle.
a little leather sewing - her school pencil case.
Her initials in varying sizes, large and then small.
There are two lists, one of what was destroyed on Kristallnacht.
Her signet ring and a locket with her maiden initials on,
are nowhere to be found.